today on the matt walsh show an activist
attempted to assassinate a politician in
a major american city this happened
yesterday and already is out of the news
you may have already guessed why but
we'll discuss today also the new mayor
of new york is getting a lot of props
from people on the right but he's as
much of a race hustler as any other
democrat i'll play a clip that proves
that and the ceo of youtube did an
interview where she called it called on
governments across the world to pass
more laws restricting speech plus a
bipartisan bill meant to protect
children on the internet i usually say
that the worst kinds of bills are the
bipartisan ones but is this an exception
to the rule we'll take a look finally
we'll cancel a man who says that women
who don't want to see his penis in the
locker room are misogynists all of that
and more today on the matte wall show
[Music]
you know the pro-life movement must
maintain its momentum now more than ever
and what better way to help than by
supporting the charities and causes that
you care about even if the supreme court
were to strike down roe v wade um
abortion would still exist in america it
would still remain legal in many states
including the most populated states in
the country most most of them anyway
charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company they partner with you to
automatically support the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice with five
percent of your monthly plan price and
they've sent millions of dollars to
charities so far and will send millions
more over the years ahead new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping when you mention offer
code walsh certain restrictions apply
charging mobile makes it easy to switch
you could keep your existing phone
number you might even be able to keep
your existing phone but if you need a
new phone no problem charity mobile has
a variety of options from the latest 5g
phones to low-cost smartphones and basic
phones as well
all of their monthly plans include
unlimited domestic minutes and uh
messages and and you can it can be
shared by up to eight lines on a family
plan there are no contracts there no
termination fees and no risk with their
30-day guarantee so switch to charity
mobile and support the causes you care
about call them at 1-877
or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh
so in may of 2021 a prominent blm
activist
black nationalist and future attempted
assassin quintes brown wrote another
op-ed for the louisville courier journal
titled louisville's huge police budget
is the real boogeyman traumatizing black
people
now in the piece he talks about all the
ways that he as a black man has suffered
because of the police in his city
and the best way to heal his trauma he
argues and rescue the city from violence
is to reduce the police budget
and he claims that louisville police are
are not good at preventing crime anyway
and so the best way to solve that
problem is to give them fewer resources
to work with
it's a it's actually a familiar argument
always coming from the same people who
say that every problem in the education
system can be solved by increasing the
budget
so to review if police aren't doing
their jobs effectively give them less
money if teachers aren't doing their
jobs effectively give them more striking
logic you must admit but this article
from brown was the last that he would
write for the publication one of the
first back in 2019 was a lamentation
about the lack of gun control in
kentucky and across the country brown
claimed that kentucky's concealed carry
law shows your life doesn't matter to
gun-loving republicans
in between this article and his arrest
this past weekend for trying to shoot
and kill a white mayoral candidate in
the city brown was intricately involved
in blm activism and he was honored for
his activism actually hailed by barack
obama's foundation as a rising face
in the social justice movement he became
a member of the youth violence
prevention league if you can believe it
and he was a local political candidate
for metro council district five so this
guy this guy got around a couple years
ago he was given a platform on msnbc
where joy reid interviewed him about uh
this same problem of gun violence listen
to this
you're from the home state of the senate
majority leader what do you want what do
you want him to know well i want you to
know that you know
we are here and we won't we won't common
sense gun reform and if you're not going
to give us that then we're going to get
everyone out here to vote and we're
going to vote you out of office so if
you want to keep your job yeah then you
know give us what we not what we want
but what we need what humans need we
need common sense gun reform get rid of
those heart rifles come on like yeah
when are you guys going to turn 18. i'll
turn 18 september 25th i'm already timed
and already ready
29th so we're registered and you guys
are making the connection that you
believe that this is about being in the
voting booth definitely
emma gonzalez she already put an
emphasis on it like because we do have
some very inflexible congressmen so
maybe we won't get gun reform like the
next day but non-violent direct action
takes time it's not going to happen
overnight so one thing that we can do is
get people out here voting because even
if we don't get gun reform we're going
to vote the people in office out and
we're going for people who want gun
reform who care about us we're going to
put them in office
non-violent direct action takes time and
uh he gave it about i don't know 18
months before he started shooting people
but quintus brown is tired of gun
violence he says so tired of it that he
allegedly walked into mayoral candidate
craig greenberg's office and shot at him
at close range and missed every shot
somehow now in fairness brown does say
in the clip that he wants to get rid of
assault rifles whatever those are he
doesn't say anything about a nine
millimeter which is what he used in his
assassination attempt so you know talk
about a loophole but no matter what sort
of gun he used the end result is that a
prominent and celebrated black
nationalist blm activist tried to
assassinate a politician in a major
american city this happened yesterday
morning and it's already out of the
headlines
because this is the part of the story
that comes as no surprise it's the part
of the story where the story disappears
already you can check the home pages of
cnn msnbc nbc news etc all the usual
suspects and find no mention at all
anywhere of quintez brown
the memory hole is dark and deep and it
does not suck things into itself slowly
like quicksand instead it will
obliterate unwanted facts and events in
the blink of an eye
the media of course has gotten very good
at quickly and quietly snuffing out
stories of black nationalists and blm
activists committing politically
motivated murders because they've had a
lot of practice
it was only a few months ago that
another member of this ideological group
plowed his car into dozens of white
people in a parade intentionally
targeting them injuring over 60 people
killing six including a child in
waukesha
that story was on its way to getting
tossed into the pit as soon as the race
of the perpetrator was known and then
when his politic politics came into
focus its fate was sealed
but before waukesha and in the same year
a capital police officer was murdered
when a black nationalist named noah
green rammed his car into a barricade
and attacked cops with a knife
officer brian siknik was was not
actually killed by rioters on january
6th though you know his name because the
media attempted to connect the two
events but in this case a capital police
officer was actually murdered by a
political extremist
straight-up murder
you don't know his name it was william
evans by the way because his death was
not useful to the narrative
you also probably don't remember the
so-called black hebrew israelites who
shot up a jewish deli in new jersey it's
only a couple years ago then got into a
shootout with the cops ultimately left
six people dead
hopefully though you remember the
extremists who assassinated five police
officers with a sniper rifle at a blm
rally in dallas in 2016. though the
media is so effective at erasing these
events from the public consciousness
that even that massacre seems to have
been mostly forgotten by the public
you know we hear quite a lot about the
the looming threat of white nationalism
and yet the majority of murderers in
this country and the majority of murders
are carried out by people who don't
quite fit that description
and even if we were to narrow the
category down to ideologically or
politically or racially motivated
violence
still most culprits don't exactly look
like white nationalists
blm itself and its various ideological
cousins and offshoots
is by far and away the most dangerous
and violent organization in america
second only to planned parenthood
perhaps
blm activists have been involved in
targeted acts of violence like this
assassination attempt also large-scale
campaigns of brutal chaos and anarchy
entire neighborhoods and cities have
been consumed by this whirlwind for days
and weeks on end
now violent political movements and
organizations
have always existed in this country and
and always will
in this country and across the world and
everywhere for all time as long as
they're along as long as there's
politics
as long as there's human society there
are going to be violent political
movements and violent people now in some
ways you might argue that blm isn't much
different from the ones that came before
it or will come after it in that way but
the difference
and what makes blm so uniquely dangerous
is that it has systemic support we hear
a lot about the problems in the system
systemic well it has systemic support
it's propped up encouraged
funded facilitated
by the most powerful institutions in the
country
now this is also why right-wing
extremists so-called
could never be as dangerous as blm even
if they wanted to wanted to be
and i'm sure that some of them do
i'm sure some of them look at blm and
say i wish we could do that
but they can't
because no matter what they do they
can't get amazon on their side
or facebook or the education system or
the government
blm has all of that
and it has the media of course
and the media's most important job on
blm's behalf
is to make sure that we all have very
short memories
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well with the ever increasing numbers of
car makes and models it's now impossible
to stock all the parts you need in a
traditional chain storefront why go
there and endure the torture of walking
around
and trying to find what you need and
being asked all of these intimidating
questions
about cars which are very intimidating
for someone like me about the
specifications of your vehicle only to
have the guy behind the counter order
the parts on his gun let's go on his
computer anyway you could cut out the
middleman and just do that yourself you
have computers with access to
rockauto.com at your home in your pocket
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years and go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they have everything you might need from
engine control modules brake parts
uh tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door the rockauto.com catalog is unique
and very easy to navigate and best of
all
uh it's all of the prices are very
affordable it's the best prices you're
gonna find anywhere so go to
rockauto.com right now and see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and remember to write walsh in there how
did you hear about xbox so they know
that we sent you all right so we'll
start uh with this eric adams is the new
mayor of new york and we could say that
he's better than
bill de blasio which i mean which he is
but it's like you know it's like damning
with faint praise it's like saying that
a woman is hotter than nancy pelosi or
something
um but he gets credit from the right
for some reason maybe part of it is
because the bar has been so low this in
some ways this is the best job in the
world is to come in
right after bill de blasio the the bar
is at this point under the earth all you
have to do is walk on the ground and
you're getting over the bar you don't
have to raise your your legs up that
high um so part of it might be that
um some of it is the is the um kind of
the lip service that he's paid to law
and order and everything else
um but the fact is that he's still
firmly on the left
and he attacks
he also goes after the left he goes
after democrats but he does it from the
left so here's a good example uh this is
the mayor of new york that even a lot of
conservatives seem to like
lecturing the media yesterday
on diversity before we play this clip
even this clip what i'm about to play
for you
the reason that i saw this is because
other conservatives on twitter were
sharing this and saying yeah go eric
adams
because of this lecture on diversity in
the media
uh let's let's listen to some of this
i'm a black man that's the mayor
but my story has been interpreted by
people that don't look like me
we gotta be honest about that
how many blacks are in editorial boards
how many blacks have determined how
these stories are being written
how many asians
how many east indians how many south
asians
everybody talks about my government
being diversified
what's the diverse diversification in
the newsrooms
so everybody go back with their
predispositions
and my
role as mayor is being interpreted
possibly
uh he says
what what where's the diversity in the
newsrooms i mean there's there's
where are the black people and the asian
people in newsrooms i don't know all
over the place what are you talking
about they're it's it's the newsrooms
are actually pretty diverse
but listen to what he listen to what he
says like why does it matter okay he's a
black man who's the mayor we've noticed
great
um
and he says that well but but i i need
black people to be to be covering me
because no one else can do it fairly and
he wants when he's given a press
conference he wants the entire room to
look like him
and why is that why do why why do you
need why does it matter
you know when when um
whenever a story is whenever i see a
headline or story in the media about me
um i know that it's always going to be
negative but it doesn't really
matter to me i don't check to see the
race of the person
is this a white person do they can they
relate to my lived experience
because i know no matter what they look
like it's going to be it's going to be
negative they're going to be tearing me
apart
so why exactly do you need them to look
like you let's let's keep listening
maybe eric adams will explain
role as mayor is being interpreted
through the prisms of your realities and
not mine
so when you write stories
not writing stories for people who was
almost homeless like me
you're not writing stories for people
who were arrested and beat by police
officers
you're not writing stories from those
who are dealing with high crime
you're writing from your prisms and i'm
not saying this to attack
but my administration is going to be
about saying the obvious that other
people are uncomfortable with saying
discomfort is growth
so i say that to all your owners of your
papers your editorials diversify
your newsroom so i can look out and see
people that look like me
and say we're going to write stories
based on the prisms that we have based
on the prism of this young man based on
the prism of being the first black woman
that's the speaker or jumani williams
based on the prisms of his realities
it's not what we're getting
that's not what we're getting and that's
why i'm covered the way i'm covered
i'm not comfortable with it
uh he's the the negative headlines are
because he's black so that's and and
he's saying
uh look i'm going to say the things that
other people won't say i'm going to sit
up here and talk tough and i'm going to
say things that other people aren't
comfortable saying
what are you talking about this
everybody says this
calling for more diversity i'm i you
know what i'm going to tell like it is
i'm going to say the things that nobody
will say and here it is we need more
diversity dude literally everyone every
person in front of a camera says that
except for me and like three other
people okay
everyone says that
but why why does it matter why why why
this obsession with when i look out here
i don't see people who look like me who
cares if they look like you or not
difference does that make
how does that how does that affect their
ability to cover you fairly or unfairly
well because he says
that um
if you're white
you're his exact wording
you're writing through the prism of your
reality and not mine
well yes that's true but
you see the problem eric is that's the
only way that any of us can engage with
the world that's the only way that any
any of us can do anything we are all
operating within
as you say the prism of our own reality
now
that doesn't mean we all get our own
reality we don't all get our own truth
but
we are all
coming from our own perspectives that's
the only perspective we can have it's
the only one available to us unless you
have a split personality disorder and
you have multiple pers perspectives
bouncing around in your head most of us
who are not mentally ill have just the
one that's it
we're all conscious beings and we have
our own perspective but
there's still there's still one shared
reality and so the goal of everybody
should be to
be to better understand
the reality that we're all a part of
and to sort of hone your your
perspective so that it comports with
reality
and that it's it's it is based in
reality
what he's saying is that you
you have really no right to talk about
him
unless you have his perspective
which number one there's the assumption
that everybody with his skin color has
exactly his perspective on life which is
incredibly degrading demeaning and
dehumanizing
that that assumption and we know of
course it's not accurate
uh you know i'm assuming
he says he wants people to look like him
in the newsroom uh covering him you know
i'm guessing that if candace owens
walked in there he would say well no not
her i don't want her
so someone else who looks like me
but also the the incredibly arrogant
assumption that everyone has to adopt
your perspective on reality
just because it's yours
and they can't say anything about you
unless they have your perspective
exactly
of course there's a lot of that kind of
thing going on going around today and
we'll uh we'll get into some of that
again in the daily cancellation um i've
had this clip for a few days and we
haven't played it we'll play it now i've
just been waiting i've been waiting for
an opportunity whenever we get to a
chance where we're dumping on eric adams
we'll just throw this in as well because
here he is a couple of days ago not
quite as important but he's speaking out
about um
about
the value of plant-based diets because
this is an important thing that we need
the mayor of new york to be talking
about uh let's listen to that
you brought up your eating habits i just
want to clarify something how often do
you eat fish and do you eat any other
animal proteins
i eat a plant-based scented life
some people want to call me vegan vegans
eat oreos and they drink coca-cola i
don't
i ate a plant-based scented life
and those who are the food police for me
they can food police all the time i ate
a plant-based centered life
i eat a plant-based scented life and i'm
not going down that hold on hold on hold
on please don't do that yelling out
stuff with me i don't do it to you don't
do it to me
i did plants based scented life and i'm
not going down this rabbit hole of what
do you eat if you eat cake and it has
eggs in it that you analyze it i'm not
doing that the more plant-based you eat
the better and healthier you are that is
my question to those who are following
me around in restaurants wondering what
i'm ordering listen i'm not doing that
that's noise to me i gotta get new
yorkers to eat a plant-based scented
light
to eat what again i didn't i didn't
catch it he didn't mention it enough
times what was it oh a plant-based
centered life what is with the mayors of
new york by the way and their obsession
with controlling what people eat i mean
he's certainly not it's it seems to be a
sickness that they all there's something
there in a town hall i don't know what
it is some kind of virus and as soon as
they become mayors they they think it's
their business to tell everyone what
they should be eating uh so he has a
plant-based centered life by the way i'm
glad we played that clip
because um
perfect perfect follow-up to the thing
before this guy's complaining about the
way the media covers him as if they're
so hard on him this is what you're
complaining about their question was
tell us more about your diet mayor
hey mayor say i've heard you like salads
can you tell us more about that
those are the difficult questions you're
whining about
by the way plant-based centered life
veganism is is uh completely unnatural
it's it's really in in many ironic ways
like the most inorganic way to live um
we were not we're not built we're not
made to eat only vegetables to eat to
eat a plant-based centered life that's
not how we're it's our our teeth aren't
the way they they are so that we can
only chop on celery and lettuce uh we
are supposed to be omnivores we meet and
vegetables and um
if if all human beings through history
going back into time
led plant-based centered lives then the
human rights would be extinct we
wouldn't exist anymore
so maybe that's maybe that's not a
coincidence like ultimate like the
vegans they're they're proposing
a way of life which by the way is a very
very privileged this is this is veganism
only exists among the most privileged
and wealthy people it is just like
gender theory gender ideology just like
so many other things critical race
theory it's another invention of the
left that can only exist in the context
of white western
privilege because you go anywhere else
in the world go to any third world
country go anywhere anywhere else you
see the way other people live this is
not an option
okay they're they're living off of uh
off of cows and and livestock they have
to hunt
if they tried to lead a plant-based
center life they would die so if
everyone becomes vegan then
within three months uh three billion
people are probably dead because they
would starve to death
and if everyone was always vegan from
the beginning of time then none of us
would be here maybe that's not a
coincidence
that veganism is uh is bob this is my
conspiracy theory veganism is a
population control tactic
it's anti-human
it's wrong and it's stupid
that's my position
um all right moving on i want to play
this for you the ceo of youtube
was interviewed i'm not sure where what
what show she was on but
this is
quite troubling in a number of ways and
it should be getting more headlines than
it is
but she was interviewed and uh here she
is talking about the ways that youtube
will suppress speech at the behest of
the government
but she she
she wants to suppress speech but her
point is that she needs the government
she needs governments around the world
to help her and sort of team up with her
in this effort to suppress speech let's
listen to that we work around the globe
and you're right certainly there are
many different laws in many different
jurisdictions and we
um we enforce the laws of the various
jurisdictions around
speech or what's considered safe or not
safe um that's true for for
democratically elected governments um it
might get a little bit more complicated
in
in non-democratically elected
governments um
and and for the most part you know so
basically we we enforce those laws um
that actually hasn't been the
controversial part what has been the
controversial part has been when there
is content that would be deemed as
harmful but yet is not illegal um so an
example of that for example would be
kovid i'm not aware of there being
laws by government saying around coven
in terms of not being able to debate the
efficacy
of masks or where the virus came from or
the right treatment or proposal but yet
there was a lot of pressure and concern
about us
distributing misinformation that went
against what was considered the standard
and accepted medical knowledge um
and so this category of harmful
but not
um
but but legal has been i think where
most of the discussion has been
and you know for us we look at that
content and we think about the the role
that we play in society um we want to be
doing the right thing for our users and
for our creators um we also generate
revenue from advertisers and if we are
serving content that is seen by our
advertising community as not benefiting
society um no advertiser is going to
want to appear on that and they're
certainly not going to even want to
appear on a different you know content
that is positive if they think the
platform as a whole is not being
responsible so we are generally very
aligned responsibility is really is good
for our business and we
uh you know we have over 2 million
creators on our platform that we share
revenue with so if we're not
generating revenue for them
then you know that's a problem for our
creators um they create
beautiful and incredible content and we
share the majority of revenue with them
so um
yeah so basically that's like you know
so i think governments like can can
always you know our recommendation if
governments want to have more control
over online speech is to to pass laws to
have that be very cleanly and clearly
defined such that we can implement it
yeah i had to get all the way to the end
there to that to that part because that
was important
um first of all i i agree with some of
what you said about youtube creators
making beautiful and amazing content
like for example this content so i
appreciate that susan thank you for that
but notice also as she says that
it's it's it's really pretty troubling
on a number of levels uh she says that
of course
we want to get rid of content that's
harmful which is um as always an
extremely broad category and uh it is
you want to talk about operating through
your own prism the prism of your reality
as eric adams says um that's gonna it's
gonna depend very much on the prism of
your reality
um what you consider to be harmful
and
so you you put that into in the terms of
service and say oh yeah we'll allow all
speech unless it's harmful
and what's harmful it's what
literally whatever we say is harmful is
harmful and in in whatever way it
doesn't matter it's it's totally up to
us
but then she goes so far as to say that
we want to make sure
that the content benefits society
and and makes the rather hilarious claim
that advertisers are worried about
benefiting society that advertisers only
want to be associated with things that
benefit society
and we know of course when it comes to
marketing departments and uh you know
i've been in marketing meetings before
and uh that's of course in every
marketing
advertising meeting the first thing
anyone talks about is how is this going
to benefit society right
um if if by society we just mean like
the
their bottom line that's the only thing
course they're worried about so we want
to make sure that the content benefits
society she says
but
and and she's she's very willing and
eager to suppress content that does not
quote benefit society or is not harmful
but it's helpful for helpful for her if
governments will pass laws and give her
that cover and so she's she's asking
she's asking
governments of the world to pass laws
ostensibly restricting her and her
company she wants those laws because it
gives her the cover she needs to
suppress the content so there is this
this unholy matrimony between big tech
and governments of the world which is
why
this is not a simple issue of of private
property this is not a simple issue of
private businesses
you know being able to control their own
business and decide who they do business
with and who they associate with
that applies
exactly to the situations where the left
refuses to apply it like for example
small independent bakeries in colorado
who don't want to make gay wedding cakes
okay a small bakery in colorado who says
to a gay couple i will sell you anything
in the store you can have anything you
want you can even have a wedding cake
what i can't do is make a customized
wedding cake where i put the little the
two little male figures on top of the
wedding cake that i can't do i could
sell you the cake you could go somewhere
else and get the little figurines and
put it on there and you're gonna or you
can go to any of the 50 other bakeries
within a five mile radius and get
exactly what you want
um
now
that situation of course is not a
hypothetical situation that's the
masterpiece cake shop case
uh
that is a totally private business
who should have the ability and the
right to decide who they associate with
and who they do business with and what
kind of business they do and if they say
we're a bakery and we make different
kinds of customized cakes but we don't
make cakes for gay weddings they should
have the right to do that
now the left though says oh that doesn't
because that's a
you know this is a
this is an accommodation this is a
service that everyone has a right to
and it causes great damage to the gay
couples if they're not able to get the
service that they want at this
particular bakery um
but then when it comes to youtube a
multi-billion dollar conglomerate
now they say oh it's a private business
they can do what they want it is exactly
reversed
the
the the bakery
has no it has no institutional power
that has no relationship with government
in fact the government is against the
bakery there's like this conspiracy of
governments on every level from the
local to the state to federal
trying to take down masterpiece cake
shop but they've been doing it for years
now
so they have no power from the
government there's no relationship there
and also
no harm is really done on a societal
level
if uh if a gay couple can't get a cake
from this particular can't get one
particular type of cake from this one
particular bakery
over on youtube though or facebook or
twitter
you have
extraordinarily powerful institutions
that are in direct um
conversation with the government there's
this alliance between these are not
independent institutions anymore there's
this alliance between them and the
government
um and
what's what's the penalty
if these supposed private businesses
decide that they don't want to do
business with you
with with the bakery the penalty is okay
you just got to go down the shop to
another bakery and get exactly the same
cake you wanted and you're fine so it's
a slight inconvenience
but with
youtube and facebook and twitter if they
decide they want to de-platform you they
are erasing you from the modern public
square which is on the internet they're
they are taking your voice out of the
conversation they're basically they are
erasing your perspective in your opinion
and they're depriving you of the ability
to participate in the national
conversation so-called
um
which is why the private business thing
doesn't
shouldn't apply to them it's a very
different sort of situation
all right
um let's go right into this i think it's
an interesting interesting follow-up
this is from the daily wire it says a
bill with bipartisan support
will be introduced in the senate on
wednesday that would require social
media companies to add additional steps
to protect children under the age of 16.
the kids online safety act co-sponsored
by tennessee republican centers our
senator marcia blackburn and connecticut
democrat
senator richard blumenthal seeks to
increase safety standards in the wake of
child safety concerns the proposed bill
requires social media platforms to
provide a safe default environment and
to help prevent potentially destructive
impacts
a statement from blumenthal's office
says the legislation also requires
independent audits and supports public
scrutiny from experts and academic
researchers to ensure that parents and
policymakers know whether social media
platforms are taking meaningful steps to
address risks to kids
blackburn added protecting our kids and
teens online is critically important
particularly since covet increased our
reliance on on technology
um
the uh
let's see bloomington also highlighted
the importance of internet safety as a
top priority for children he said the
kids online safety act would finally
give kids and their parents the tools
and safeguards they need to protect
against toxic content and hold big tech
accountable for deeply dangerous
algorithms
um
now
this is another thing
you know you
the people who say that we can't put any
restrictions on youtube
um you know or the the people that talk
about
private businesses and and what sort of
restrictions we should have on them you
know this is now we have a breakdown
here and there's a lot of
inconsistencies with um what kind of
rules can we put in place for children
what i would say there is is first of
all
um
i think i think we have to acknowledge
number one
this is this is my only problem my only
issue with trying to make social media
safer for kids my only issue with it
is that social media is
is inherently dangerous for kids so
there is there is no way to actually
make it safer it's an unsafe thing to do
so if you have if you have your uh 15
year old
on
instagram or tiktok
yeah it could be safer than it is right
now because right now they're subjected
to
just this it's like a it's like a broken
sewage line spraying directly in their
face every time they go on the internet
and they have access to all of the the
worst content in the world bombarding
them at uh the speed of light right
so it could be better but it can never
actually be safe so i go back to the
analogy of you know it's like it's like
recommending that a drunk driver put
their seatbelt on
it's safer if you're gonna drink and
drive it's definitely safer to have your
seatbelt on but it's not a safe activity
the better thing is just to not drink a
drive in the first place and the better
thing for kids is to not let them on
social media to begin with
really keep them away from the internet
as much as possible
but the reality is that a lot of parents
are allowing this even though they
shouldn't
and um so can we make the internet a
little bit safer for kids i think
obviously we should
and so there are two categories
you know there's a
restrictions put in place to to protect
adults from so-called harmful content
and then as i said there's always this
subjective nature of what do you mean by
harmful exactly
that's one conversation
but with kids
you know society has a special duty to
protect children
and this is a responsibility that that
almost all societies throughout history
have recognized without even really
needing to talk about it
um it's only in modern society where
this is that where this is a discussion
where we actually have to talk about
whether we should do that or not whether
we should protect kids
we're we're in a position right now
where an eight-year-old kid
can just
go on the internet
and go to google and in two seconds
he is bombarded with all of the worst
filth i mean the kinds of images and
things and ideas and
acts that um even adults prior to modern
age never would have encountered and a
kid at eight is exposed to this stuff
and continually exposed to it
all through his formative years
and we're so stupid that we actually
have a conversation about whether we
should do anything to try to prevent
that from happening
we actually have a conversation about
whether there should be any laws in
place at all
to control these companies and to make
sure they put safeguards in place so
that at least eight-year-olds aren't
exposed to this filth
we shouldn't need to talk about it of
course there should be laws and i think
this is a good start all right um
here's the latest on the kim and kanye
drama from buzzfeed
i don't know why i'm reading this but
we'll read some of it
uh it says fans are expressing concern
on social media after kanye west leaked
some distressing messages allegedly from
kim kardashian
but i'm reading this because everyone's
talking about this and so i assume it
must be important because people on the
internet don't talk about anything that
isn't important i've learned but before
we get into fans responses here's a
quick reminder of how we reach this
point says buzzfeed
as i'm sure you're aware kim filed for
divorce from kane who legally changed
his name to yay did he way back in
february 2021 citing
irreconcilable differences
the pair who share four children
together
their names are north saint chicago and
psalm
this sounds like coordinates on a map
that doesn't sound like names of the
kids um appeared to be functioning
amicably as co-parents in the initial
wake of the split however things took a
turn a few months down the line in
october after room okay who cares about
this so what's the latest on this i
guess um kim kardashian is sending kanye
west messages
because kanye west has been going after
kim because she's uh
as i'm talking about this i'm wondering
why
kim kardashian is dating pete davidson
the snl guy and kanye west is dating
some other some some other chicks and
some model
and uh kanye west doesn't like pete
davidson and
so kim kardashian has been messaging
kanye saying please stop talking about
this publicly and then kanye proceeds to
post all of those text messages on
instagram of his wife his ex-wife
begging him to keep everything private
and um so it's been a big topic of
conversation people taking both sides of
it
here's what i'll say about this
um
a couple general
principles and the first is there is
very rarely
a clear-cut good guy
in a marital dispute
i'm not saying there there never is and
there are certainly occasions where one
person in the relationship is obviously
the villain
and you can pin the blame on him or her
for why everything fell apart that's the
case sometimes
but most of the time it isn't
and
uh you you can tell that this is the
case because if you've ever been in the
proximity of a relationship that's
falling apart
and maybe you're you know you're you're
getting the gossip from one member of
that relationship and they're telling
you everything and you're thinking oh
this other person's as a scumbag i had
no idea
and then you think at some point to talk
to the other person and you hear their
side of it and you're thinking okay well
there's a lot of details there the other
person left out that's almost always the
way that it goes because
human relationships are very complicated
and when you've got two people they're
married they've lived together for a
long time
um they uh things start going sour
usually
it takes two people to get married and
usually it takes two people for the
marriage to fall apart it takes the
usually takes the consent of both people
in some way
and normally that's because um when you
listen to both sides you realize that oh
both of these people
are selfish a-holes both of these people
are incredibly selfish were only focused
on themselves the entire time and that's
why everything fell apart
i suspect that's probably the case here
in fact i'm quite certain it is
because
they
i don't know all the particulars of
their relationship
but before you go on the internet and
take sides in something like this which
is
a stupid thing to do
even when you know the people it could
be stupid because you don't know
everything that went on uh in that
relationship but when you don't know
them in their celebrities it's even
dumber to take sides especially in this
case because here's what we know
um they have four kids and they got
divorced
so that's strike one against them
you know you ha you have kids now
really
once you get married the deal should be
sealed because you've made that pledge
to your betrothed
in sickness and health for life
and you get divorced and you're breaking
that promise but when you have four kids
then you just gotta suck it up and if
you go through you go through a rough
spot in your marriage
um that's just something that you deal
with you go to counseling or something
um
instead of throwing your kids into this
turmoil so they've both done that
and also they both immediately went and
found other people and are parading
around in public with their with this
other person while their kids are
watching and aware of all of it kanye
west is doing that kim kardashian is
doing that so
there are no good guys here
i'm afraid to say
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
hey dailywire.com sweet baby comments if
you want to leave a video comment let's
um
okay we have a comment here taking issue
with my stance i think on sandwiches
let's listen to that first
hey sweet day walls just wanted to say i
totally agree
that jersey mike's absolutely at the top
of the chain sandwich restaurant chain
but i disagree where you put arby's on
the list rv should absolutely be number
two on the list
they should go jersey mike's arby's and
then jimmy john's
if you don't agree with me cancel me bro
spg for life
um well yeah thanks for that and i mean
it is an important an important
conversation um you know normally i'm
very quick to ban anyone from the show
for being wrong you are wrong but
um you've aired on the right side i
think you've aired on the pro rb side
and so i'm um
that's acceptable i'll i'll i will allow
that
um i was ready to get very upset when
you when you first started talking about
arby's because i thought you were going
to tell me as many people have that they
don't even deserve to be in the
conversation for best sandwich chain
uh and i find that deeply offensive i
mean arby's is number one take sandwich
chains out of it when it comes to just
sort of like dr fast food drive-through
uh the kind that you you know you might
see a sign for on when you're when
you're going down the highway i'm i put
arby's at the top of that list certainly
above mcdonald's wendy's i put him above
all that uh you you always know there's
a certain consistent quality with arby's
that you always know you're gonna get
um
so if you want to put them up higher on
the list i'm not gonna take issue with
that actually so i won't ban you from
the show i mean you are wrong
because
it it's it's still
superior when you can go into the
sandwich chain and you can actually
watch them assemble uh the the sandwich
and then you're not gonna have the same
sogginess and stuff with the bread and
everything but now we're getting into
particulars and uh
uh but that's that's fine all right
let's go to uh clip nine here
hey matt i'm so glad my husband listens
to your show this is my valentine's gift
i was so excited i instantly knew who
gave him the idea sweet baby gang for
life
so she's holding this is a this is a
happy wife with a very attentive and
romantic husband who has given her
apparently um 409 cleaner some clorox
wipes and clorox wipes and then i can't
tell she's oh uh some rubber gloves some
cleaning supplies so
it look i i
you could tell from from her expression
this might be the smile of a woman who
just if you were to pan the camera a
little bit you would see her husband
dead on the floor and his blood is
spoiling on the floor maybe that's why
she has the the rubber gloves there
because she's cleaning it up that might
be the smile we're seeing there i don't
know but
look
women um
if i've learned anything as you know
married for 10 years i'm a love guru i'm
an expert in this
live women they spend a lot of time in
the kitchen spend a lot of time cleaning
and uh they when it comes to gifts
they always
value practicality so that's why you
know you know they don't want jewelry
what are you gonna do with jewelry what
do you do with flowers they want things
that they can use vacuum toaster
cleaning supplies
take it from me
all right um
this is from two sides one stone says i
never understood the sticks and stones
narrative ever since i was a child
physical assault slash abuse is proven
to be far easier to overcome than
psychological abuse we have uh need for
more and better psychologists for a
reason while
while physical therapists are a dime a
dozen it's a coward's way out to pass
the responsibility on to the child
because the adult doesn't have the guts
just to
discipline children or approach parents
of other children
you're being bullied not me here's a
catchy tune so i don't have to do
anything now leave me alone then kids
commit suicide and no one saw it coming
shifting blame yet again
okay
um first of all i would take uh
the
the abuse of a child by an adult
we're gonna put that in obviously i
think into a separate category here
um if if a child is
is
the victim of a sustained abuse by an
adult then no one is going to look at
that child and say sticks and stones
right of course
what we're talking about
is um
the kind of run-of-the-mill
things that you run into
as a human being in the world
an adult with another adult who says
something mean to you or as a child when
you're at school and kids say mean
things to you
that's just part of being a human being
and that's where the sticks and stones
rhyme i think actually does apply it's a
good reminder and it's true
now you say kids kids commit suicide
um at alarming rates and they do and
oftentimes we link that to bullying at
school and that sort of thing
but kids don't commit suicide because of
words that are said to them
okay there's not a direct causal link
there
or at the very least you're leaving
something out a really important
ingredient
they commit suicide
because of the weight
that they put on those words
the weight that they put on the approval
of their peers
that's why we're seeing this
uptick in childhood suicide and i say
uptick because
you know 60 70 years ago you just this
kind of thing it almost never happened
you just didn't hear about it happening
and now it's quite common
um
and why is that
kids these days
depend on their peers approval to a
really obsessive overwhelming degree
and i don't blame the kids for that it's
not their fault
they didn't create the society that
they're in now
but they're thrust into an environment
first of all many of them they go to
school um and they're with their peers
physically for
you know six or seven hours a day five
days a week nine months a year for 12 or
13 years so this is they spend most of
their time
with their peers and they feel like it's
it's almost survival they need their
their peers to approve approve of them
um
and kids also they're not very good at
looking at things long term adults
aren't good at it either
so a kid
you know
you might tell him that hey look you're
going to graduate high school you're
never going to see most of these people
ever again and a lot of the bullies
you're gonna look back 10 years after
you graduate and their lives are
miserable and everything you can tell
them that but they just they can't see
that all they see is what's right in
front of them in this environment
they're in every day and so they they
need the approval of the people they
spend all this time with
and then you add to that on the internet
and social media
where
even after they leave
the physical school building
they're still in this pure culture
they're still they still carry their
friends around with them in their
pockets and they can't escape it ever
and it becomes suffocating it's
overwhelming
um
and because they depend so much then
psychologically and appears approval
when they get mean comments when they
when that approval is taken away from
them it becomes this catastrophe
the point of sticks and stones is to
emphasize though that a person's words
only have the power that you give it
so there
there is an important message there
that yeah a person might say something
mean to you and they might want to hurt
you
but it only it can only hurt you
if you care about that person's opinion
if you choose to put weight on that
person's words that's the only way you
can be hurt by what they say to you
and it's the reason why people say mean
things to me all the time and none of it
hurts me because i don't care what any
of them think their opinions mean
nothing to me
and that's the point of the message
if somehow you missed the world premiere
of shut-in this past weekend head to
dailywire.com subscribe to get a
membership today the film is now
exclusively streaming for daily wire
members and currently has a critic score
of 100
an audience score of 97 so this is wide
acclaim from both critic and audience
audiences which is um
pretty rare these days we are creating
more and more great entertainment
without a leftist agenda and it's all
thanks to our daily wire members you
guys make this possible so head to
dailywire.com subscribe today so you can
watch shut in and then we've also got
other movies coming out hyperions gina's
new movie coming out this summer all of
that is available go to dailywire.com
subscribe
and the best way you know to fight the
insidious attack on america is to expose
the source from within introducing one
of the daily wire's newest projects the
enemy within our new series featuring
acclaimed journalist and expert in
national threads lee smith
in the show smith uncovers a political
coup orchestrated by america's ruling
elites to generate their own wealth and
power at the expense of the american
people's safety and freedom from fouchy
to our educational system to hollywood
and everything in between each episode
will take you deep into what's going on
behind the scenes what those who are
supposed to be protecting you don't want
you to know check out the trailer
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within
you're trying to obscure responsibility
for four million people dying around the
world senator paul you do not know what
you are talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that matched the cruelty and wickedness
of many evil torturers and executioners
[Music]
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about one person
infiltrating senior levels at the cia or
the white house we're talking about an
entire elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
[Music]
the enemy within will start streaming
this friday february 18th exclusively at
daily wire so if you're not a member
now's the time to change that head to
dailywire.com subscribe to join us today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel a gentleman by the name
of james rose
sorry i suppose i should refer to him as
gentlemen rather than man because he
identifies as a they as multiple people
on his website james says that he is a
genderfluid actor living in new york
city and also includes this note
james writes about gender liberation
eating disorders uh trauma sex their
feelings and their exes on instagram
where they intend to leave the world a
little better than they found it
because you know there's no better way
to improve the world than by talking
about your feelings on instagram
but james is not just a genderfluid
actor an instagram diarist he's also a
self-described gender educator now you
may have noticed that literally anyone
can describe themselves as an educator
these days which is no surprise because
literally anyone can describe themselves
as literally anything these days no
labels have any meaning
words are all empty in this utopia of
ours so shoot for the moon i mean
speaking of which i'm going to start
describing myself as an astronaut
in fact i'm a i'm a gender astronaut
what does that mean well it's up to me
to decide your job is to listen and nod
your head respectfully as if you know
what i'm even trying to say
that brings us back to james who in his
role as gender educator will often post
tick tock videos lecturing cis women as
he calls them about all of their many
failures and foibles
most recently he posted a video
explaining to women that they're not
allowed to feel uncomfortable
when penises are flying around in front
of their faces in the locker room listen
to him a lot of cis women share this
sentiment and i do want to break it down
this may be uncomfortable to sit through
and to listen to and i think that's why
it's important that we do this feeling
like trans people are a threat to you in
a space like a bathroom or a locker room
is actually a version of internalized
misogyny which is not necessarily your
fault because it's impossible to divorce
our socialization from the prevalence of
patriarchy but it also does mean it's
our responsibility to unlearn it for the
safety of fellow women especially trans
women in my experience as a gender
educator the majority of cis women who
have experienced violence at the hands
of men or just patriarchy or living in
today's world see anything that codes to
them as remotely masculine male etc and
fear it which in many ways is a survival
tactic that makes sense the difference
is when we code trans people as the
wrong gender we're actually doing them
way more a disservice than we are
protecting ourselves because you're
ostracizing and further alienating trans
people the false media narrative and
trope around trans people is that we are
predators that are tricking people into
thinking that we're something that we're
not which is of course not true watch
the documentary disclosure on netflix if
you want more on that so being
uncomfortable with trans people in your
space is something that you were taught
and you can unlearn that it's important
to recognize that we can't tell
someone's gender by their presentation
by their genitals by the way that they
look all of that can be changed all of
that is arbitrary none of that is
central to your identity necessarily
you know
if the word mansplaining has any
application at all that would have that
would have to be it i think so let me
translate here's what our friend james
is saying to the ladies out there
he's saying shut up you stupid girls and
let him get naked in front of you
and people like this often get away with
saying the most hideous things and being
absolute tyrannical bullies and
predators because for one thing they're
in an in an approved victim group
but also because of this grading
irritating faux compassionate tone they
use now any semi-aware person can
recognize that this smug little bastard
is being condescending and patronizing
as hell
and that he's doing it in an effort to
emotionally black male women into
allowing men to sexually harass them
but the dumber non-aware people a large
demographic in this culture these days
unfortunately will hear this and they'll
say well he sounds like he's being nice
we should listen to whatever he says
the interesting thing
is that james's message which is often
the message of trans activist
is that your feelings as a woman are not
valid he all but comes out and says that
your feelings don't matter
you need to change your feelings
in fact he knows more about your
feelings than you do he's conducted a
therapeutic diagnosis
of all the women in the country all at
once and he's decided that your
discomfort with strange penis in the
locker room is internalized misogyny
did you get that
so if you as a woman
do not want to see him as a male
get naked in front of you
you are a misogynist
you are now essentially the man in that
exchange not him and he is the victim of
your misogyny
this is coercion of the most twisted
kind all in an effort to compel women to
sit quietly while men expose themselves
louis c.k was cancelled with righteous
fury by the mob when he exposed himself
in front of women except that in his
case he asked for permission ahead of
time
doesn't make it okay but he did
still it was argued that even with
consent there was implicit coercion
because of the power that he had over
the women in the interaction
well
what about men who who who do not ask
for permission before exposing
themselves and who apply explicit
coercion to shame women into silence and
acquiescence
by the standard already applied to many
high-profile men in much in much more
ambiguous circumstances these guys are
our sex predators
now the simplified view of our cultural
ethos is that feelings are given first
priority feelings matter above all else
i've often said this myself as recently
as yesterday
and it's true but the statement needs
qualification because it's more accurate
to say that some people's feelings
matter above all else
if feelings in general were given pride
of place then james rose would be
roundly condemned by everybody
for recording videos lecturing women
about the illegitimacy of their feelings
he's allowed to do this because his
feelings as a member of the lgbt camp
are of utmost importance
primary importance
but the feelings of a woman especially a
white cisgender woman quote unquote
don't necessarily rank at all
and when her feelings are made to
contest with the feelings of the sacred
alphabet people
her feelings are then ascribed a
negative value
her feelings aren't just unimportant
they're bad they're shameful they are a
sin that must be punished a disease that
must be cured
see if the left put an overemphasis on
everybody's feelings
and they were obsessively concerned with
making sure that nobody ever felt sad or
uncomfortable that would still be bad
and dangerous in its own way but at
least we could call them
well-intentioned we could even say that
their problem is an over-abundance of
compassion or a kind of misdirected
misappropriated compassion
either way
they would be good people they'd be nice
people a little bit too nice
just misguided
that's not the case though
[Music]
on balance it turns out that they care
less about feelings than even i do
because there's only a very select group
of people whose feelings rank at all and
everybody else can go to hell they say
let's look at one more clip from james
as he now responds to some of the
comments taking issue with the video we
just played listen to this
so you've caught me at the time when i'm
not feeling diplomatic and i'm just
gonna yell this is a horrible comment
and i don't need to defend any of my
behavior aka walking down the street as
a freaking non-binary woman
feeling uncomfortable with trans people
walking down the street is just your
transphobia because as a fellow femme i
understand the danger and the terror and
the fear of walking around on the street
especially at night i live in new york
city don't even get me started and
because i'm aware of what it feels like
to be on the receiving end of that as a
femme and as a non-binary woman when i
see another potentially feminine
presenting person in front of me i will
say things like coming behind on your
left or just don't want to scare you
coming behind on your right something
that lets them know that i'm there so
they don't feel fear and i do this as a
courtesy on the off chance they
misgender me and think i'm a man that's
just camaraderie and looking out for
each other the fact that you feel like i
would be unsafe on the street is
literally just a coding for i don't
conceptualize you as a non-binary person
or as a woman i don't need that energy
on my page get out
so somehow we've gone from talking about
locker rooms to walking down the street
i'm not sure when that shift in the
conversation happened but even so first
of all note how he a male identifies as
a non-binary woman
now non-binary if it means anything at
all which it doesn't means that
someone is not a man or a woman so he a
male is also a woman but also neither a
man nor a woman but also a man
and not only does he hold this
incoherent jumble of self-identities in
his confused head but it also is your
responsibility as a woman to know that
just by looking at him as he passes by
in the street
now james and his generosity
he will give you permission as a woman
to be nervous when you're alone at night
and a man walks by
he will allow that
so you should say thank you to james for
that because he's going to let you have
that feeling
say thank you mr james or miss james or
whatever
but if the man walking by identifies as
a woman or if he identifies as a woman
who identifies as neither a man nor a
woman
but is a man
then you must not feel nervous you must
intuit his self-perception in that
moment you must absorb it into your
being in a split second and if you don't
then you're transphobe
this is the way the world works
according to this pompous overbearing
megalomaniacal ass
you must conform to his version of the
world
that's what you have to do
or you can simply tell this person and
every bullying narcissist like him to
piss off and also you can tell him that
he is canceled that's what i would
recommend
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
vadowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show three san
francisco school board members lose
their jobs in a recall and the left
prepares its next war on descent with
debanking efforts that's today on the
bench bearish i'll give it a listen